Weisses Haar dem Eisenahr, in dem er ward eingefroren. Kanz. Ah, schön, dass ihr da seid. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Dieses Intro ist wie Glatteis, man kann leicht ausrutschen und dann ins Taumeln geraten. Und sich den Kopf einschlagen. Und ich halte mich noch irgendwie an dir fest, ziehe dich aber gleichermaßen mit runter, werde aber so als Stützhilfe aufprangt, an dem man sich immer gut festhalten kann, ist Stefan Maria Judokustice. Und Flo und die Dame Pascal Wilde freuen uns sehr, euch heute wieder begrüßen zu dürfen, zu einer neuen Folge des Podcasts. Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Ich klappe mich panisch an dir fest, ich reisse an dir runter, du sagst, nein, nein, so funktioniert das nicht, so funktioniert das nicht. Das Problem ist, weil ich mich auch an dir festhalte. Richtig. Und das führt zu so einer Comic, so Roadrunner-Situation, so einer Comic Situation, wo wir bar der Gesetze, der physikalischen Gesetze, wider der Natur, beide aneinander geklammert, in der Luft stehen. Aber, sei vorsichtig. Ich bin ausgebildet, denn ich bin ausgebildeter Kampftaucher, also ich habe einen Tauchkurs gemacht, als ich ein Kind war, und da haben wir auch Wasserrettung natürlich auch geprobt. Also wenn jemand in Seenot ist, Wassernot, Schwimmnot ist, dann schwimmst du da hin. Atemnot. Sagen wir mir was jetzt, du stirbst nicht daran, dass du nicht schwimmen kannst, du stirbst am Ertrinken. Ja, und dann haben wir das so geübt, wie Kinder in einem Pool. So, ja, einer irgendwie spielt so, auch da habe ich schon recht gut performt und die Panik war relativ überzeugend. Und dann kam irgendwie Jutta an und hat mich dann gerettet so und dann musst du dich so auf dem Rücken schwimmen und den Geretteten so auf dir drauf, dass du den wie so ein Boot über Wasser drückst so ein bisschen so. Und dann haben wir das so ein bisschen geübt und dann meinte der Schwimmlehrer, es kann aber auch passieren, dass der in Atemnot geratene so panisch ist, sich an dir festklammert, sodass er Gefahr läuft, beide zu ertrinken und dann müsste er in den Finger brechen.
Genau, habe ich auch mal gehört. Man muss denjenigen verletzen.
Als neunjähriger dachte mir, okay, got it, aber wie üben wir das jetzt, was genau, das wurde nie erklärt, wurde nie irgendwie Techniken oder so und ich denke immer, also wenn ich auf jemanden zuschwimmen würde, der im Petto ist zu ertrinken, denke ich mir, Sekunde, erinnere dich an das, was du gesagt hast. Du musst ihm den Finger brechen, Echen, Echen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich direkt anfangen, Finger zu brechen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viele. Also je nach Panikgrad einfach so vier bis sechs Finger brechen. Aber der Fakt, dass man nicht erklären musste, wie man den Finger bricht, sagt mir wiederum, dass es sehr einfach ist, jemandem den Finger zu brechen. Ich sag mal, ich bin in Ebersberg in Oberbayern aufgewachsen, das war ein hartes Pflaster. Da muss man neunjährigen nicht erklären, wie man Finger brecht. Also da hat jeder in der Grundschule schon mal seine acht bis neunzehn Finger gebrochen. Da kannst du davon ausgehen, dass das geht. Das geht wie Zahnstocher. Aber können wir kurz über das Wort ertrinken sprechen? Ja, bitte. Gerne. Es ist ein Comedy-Podcast. Es ist tatsächlich albern, weil du würdest ja, wenn du in so einen Kessel voller Essen fällst und daran stirbt jemand, würdest du ja nicht sagen, er hat sich überfressen. Genau, richtig. Sondern du würdest sagen, er ist qualvoll, erstickt, aber wenn du im Wasser stirbst, ertrinkst du, es klingt so, als ob du nicht genug bekommen hast. Warum ist die Gastronomiebranche überhaupt Teil dieses Erlebnis, zu sagen, ertrinken? So köstlich. Ja, ertrinken, du erstickst, du erstickst. Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen langweilig, weil das habe ich in True Crime Podcasts gehört, eigentlich ist jeder Tod ersticken. Jeder Tod ist letzten Endes im Gehirn, kommt kein Sauerstoff mehr an. Das ist immer der Tod. Egal was passiert, auch wenn du vergiftet wirst. Für mich ist ersticken nicht, es kommt kein Sauerstoff mehr im Gehirn an. Für mich, Laie. Ich spreche für uns Laien. Ach so, das hätte ich sagen müssen, ich bin kein Laie mehr. Ich spreche für uns Laien. Du hast oft die Bodenhaftung verloren. Wir Laien. Für uns ist ersticken, es kommt keine Luft mehr in der Lunge an. Ja, ich glaube, deswegen musste man sich so ein paar Wörter überlegen. Erdrosselt, erstickt, ertrunken, damit man so ein bisschen Farbe da reinbringt irgendwie. Damit du so ein bisschen unterscheiden kannst, was es ist. An der Stelle eine Serienempfehlung von mir, eine komplett ernst gemeinte Serienempfehlung. Im Gegensatz zu den Prank-Szenen-Befehlungen, wie wir jetzt 400 Folgen rauskamen. Nee, aber du empfiehlst manchmal Sachen und dann nach der Aufnahme sagst du dir, der Film ist mega scheiße. Der ist mega scheiße. Der ist mega scheiße. Der ist mega scheiße. Der ist mega scheiße. Bullshit. Und die Trottel gehen rein und schaut sich den den an! Die kaufen, die geben Geld aus dafür. Ne, krank, krank Berlin. Eine Serie könnt ihr auf Apple TV gucken, eine deutsche Produktion, eine fantastische Serie, macht richtig viel Spaß zu gucken. Toller Cast, tolle Story, sieht fantastisch aus, macht richtig, richtig Spaß. Hat mich sehr gefreut, das zu entdecken. Groß Kompliment. Moritz, danke an dein Intro. Vielen Dank da rein. Es war, glaube ich, eine Art Kammerspiel, deine eigenen Gehirnwindungen zum Thema Guido Kanz, der ja aktuell gefroren ist und sich in einem limbo-haften Zustand bewegt. Ich weiß nicht, ob er überhaupt noch denkt, wenn dein Körper gefroren ist, was genau noch überhaupt passiert in deinem Gehirn. Gibt es Gedanken ohne physische Repräsentanz, die man messen könnte? All das sind Fragen, die offen liegen im Fall Markus Kanz. Die uns nur Gito Kanz nach dem Auftauen beantworten kann. Richtig, aber das Auftauen natürlich auch quälen langsam ist. Also vor allem gibt es da nicht so die Theorien, dass wenn du einfrierst, also langsam einfrierst, das ist ja kein Schockfrosten. Moment, warum? Das ist ja kein Schockfrosten. Das weisst du. Na, das weiss ich. Du hast so ein begrenztes Wissen über diesen Vorgang des Einfriens. Ich habe mich intensiv mit Disney auseinandergesetzt, weil auch ich langsam dem grössten Wahn erliege und auch darüber nachdenke, mich einfrieren zu lassen. Machen wir in der nächsten Folge. Aber in der Folge jetzt erstmal, wenn du einfrieren, ich glaube da hat jemand gesagt, bitte lasst euch nicht einfrieren, hört endlich auf, dieser Wahnsinn muss aufhören, denn wenn du langsam einfrierst, dann je kälter etwas ist, desto langsamer wird es auch und dann werden alle Aktivitäten im Gehirn verlangsamt und für dich als subjektive Wahrnehmung, Fallend langsam. Nee, nicht der Tod, du bleibst ja am Leben, aber ich glaube nicht, dass du am Leben bleibst. Doch, Guido kannst du es tot. Sag noch mal, Hashtag Guido kannst du es tot. So, und diese Sekunden quasi vor dem Stillstand fühlen sich für dich subjektiv aber an wie Jahre, weil quasi dein Gehirn so stark verlangsamt ist, dass du so Inception-mässig sich das total langsamer anfühlst. Das heißt, für uns ist es Tschau Guido, Tschau. Wie lange sollen wir noch winken? Ah, er ist weg. Okay, wir gehen. Tschüss, ich sitze im Auto. Das ist für ihn zehn Jahre. Genau, das ist für ihn siebenhundert Jahre vielleicht. Weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist genau meine Angst, dass das jeder tot ist. Weil du hast ja gerade gesagt, wir spüren zurück, jeder tot ist eigentlich ersticken, es kommt wenig Sauerstoff im Hirn an. In meinem Gefühl, das reißt ja nicht einfach ab, sondern es kommt immer weniger an. Und diese Napsenfuhr sind immer weniger langsam. Genau. Deswegen ist tatsächlich bei einer Angst vor dem Tod vor allem die, dass es sich ewig lang anfühlt. Naja, aber vielleicht ist es dann auch nochmal gut, weil gut, weil so nach 700 Jahren denkst du dir, so jetzt können wir auch mal Schluss machen und dann findest du dich vielleicht auch besser mit dem Tod ab. Das wenn du noch mal ganz viel Zeit hast, weil alle denken, der Grund warum du dich sterben... Nach 700 Jahren, mir reichen 50. Subjektiv, ja okay, ist doch super, dann bist du halt nach 650 Jahren denkst du dir, so, voran. Das Problem am Tod ist ja, dass die Leute denken, es gibt noch so viel, was ich noch machen wollte. Ich wollte noch mal auf dem Eiffelturm hinaufklettern. Ich wollte noch mal ein riesiges Trampolin unterm Eiffelturm aufstellen und von ganz oben darauf springen. Ich wollte noch mal so fest auf das Trampolin unten am Eiffelturm aufkommen, dass ich wieder komplett nach oben zum Eiffelturm springe. Aber diese Sachen machen ja nur Spaß, wenn du noch existierst, indem du sowas machen kannst. Wenn du rumliegst, aber dein Gehirn funktioniert noch, das ist ja die Hölle. Das ist ja die wortwörtliche Hölle. Ich kann ja schon nicht mal einen Film gucken, ohne dabei auch mein Handy zu starren, weil ich Stimulus brauche. Wenn ich liege und ich hole die Krankenhausdecke an und ich sterbe langsam und es fühlt sich an wie 700 Jahre. Nicht ideal. Ganz ehrlich, nicht ideal. Herzlich willkommen beim Podcast UFO. Ihr seid bei uns in der Mitte. Der ablenkende Eskapismus-Podcast. Fan, fan, fan, fan, fan. Wie du kannst lebt und er ist gerade nicht in der lebenden Hölle gefangen, dass er in irgendeinem Gefriergefängnis gerade unendliche Qualen durchlebt. Vielleicht doch. Vielleicht tauen wir ihn zur Not einfach mal auf. Wir sind zwar ein Comedy-Podcast, aber wir sind auch kein Lügen-Podcast. Wir können euch die Angst nicht nehmen. Vielleicht erleidet Guido Kanz gerade Höllenqualen. So, das können wir euch niemals nehmen. Das ist immer eine Option. Das ist immer die Angst, die bei euch und bei uns irgendwo im Hinterkopf existiert. Immer eine Option. Egal wer, vielleicht denkt ihr gerade an eine Person, mag sein, dass der gerade auftaut oder dass irgendwo der Stecker rausgezogen wurde und Guido Kanz langsam auftaut und dann langsam verkommt auch so. Niemand weiss es, der wird dann schimmlig. Guido Kanz eingefroren. Der ist schon innen irgendwie so braun und so, ach, dann ist einfach nicht mehr richtig. Googelt das, googelt weiterhin Guido Kanz eingefroren. Ja, bitte. Ich freue mich sehr, Es ist soweit. Ich habe sie bekommen. Ich habe vor ein paar Folgen davon erzählt. Erinnerst du dich noch? Ich habe meine Farbanalyse gemacht. Ach ja, richtig. Welche Farben passen am besten zu dir? Du hast dich heute auch schon passend gekleidet. Tatsächlich? Ein kleiner Spoiler, ich habe mich perfekt gekleidet, könnt ihr bei patreon.com slash das B, er ist grau angezogen. Also, es ist super spannend, ich bin sehr happy, ich mache es mal parallel auf. Ich habe schon angekündigt, jemand in meinem Leben, eine nahe Person hat das auch gemacht. Was, wie du kannst. Exakt, wie du kannst. Und ich habe firsthand gesehen, was es macht. Gesichter strahlen plötzlich. Die richtigen Farben zum richtigen Gesicht. Es war wirklich from doubter to believer. Ich habe nicht daran geglaubt, ich halte das für eine Pseudowissenschaft. Man kann natürlich nicht abstreiten, dass manchen andere Farben besser stehen als andere, das ist ja allen klar, haben wir alle schon mal beobachtet irgendwo, bei Promis werden die über den roten Teppich sehen, keine Ahnung, jetzt Timothy Shalamay, wunderschöner Mann, recht blass. Wenn man ihm eine blasse Farbe anzieht, würde man wahrscheinlich eher sagen, unruhig, er kann es als Entscheidung natürlich trotzdem machen, aber du willst eher sagen, es macht mich nervös, auf so eine Art, es ist eher ein unkibbeliges, es macht mich hebelig, Timmy, man will hinrennen und ihm ein bisschen mehr Farbe anziehen, man will ihm schütteln und was überziehen. Man weiß nicht genau, was es ist, aber du machst mich irgendwie ganz kirre heute. Und da gibt es tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen Untersuchungen, natürlich gibt es Farben, Farbwissenschaft, aber oft Thema bei uns. Colorologie. Erst als eine neue Farbe entdeckt wurde und wir gesagt haben, Momentele, was geht da vor sich in der Farbwelt? Da haben wir kurz 30 Folgen über die Farben gesprochen. Von daher, wir wissen, dass das existiert. Aber ey, ich habe mir auch, da habe ich ja erzählt, die Bauhaus-Serie geguckt, wo Johannes Itten, einer der großen Meister der Bauhausschule, hat den Farbkreis aufgemalt. Farbtheorie, was sind Komplementärfarben, was passt zusammen, wo ist am meisten Kontrast da? Darauf basiert das Ganze auch interessanterweise. Und dann geht es um Augenfarbe, es geht um Hautuntertöne, es geht um Haarfarbe. Für uns ist das alles sehr spannend. Ich würde dich auch bitten, das zu machen. Ich finde das total spannend. Sie sind nicht fast gleich. Was du bist. Du hast halt diese toten Augen, aber sonst sind wir richtig.
Da bist du nicht identisch. Stell dir vor, wir würden die exakt gleiche Farbanalyse bekommen.
Wir sind menschlich extrem unterschiedlich. Extrem unterschiedlich. Tag und Nacht, Himmel und Hölle.
Ich könnte nicht unterschiedlicher sein als du.
Ja, aber farblich sind wir absolut identisch, übrigens auch genauso wie Heinrich Himmler.
Heinrich Himmler hat genauso wie wir die exakten, ansonsten sehr unterschiedlich, ein bisschen näher bei dir als bei dir. Ja, wenn ich jetzt anders gesagt habe. Naja, man berichtet teilweise auch, dass er zum Beispiel nicht so sozial war und nicht so rauszusagen ist. Immer wenn zwei Menschen sich vergleichen, gibt es eine Person, die näher an Himmler dran ist als die andere. Fakten. Kalte Fakten.
Kalte Fakten
sind ja richtig kalt.
Er ist einfach Faktum.
Mir gefällt, was du sagst. Gar nicht wertend.
Nee, bei zwei Personen.
Natürlich ist Heinrich Himmler irgendwo
dazwischen. Vielleicht sogar
fast genau in der Mitte.
Vielleicht 50%, vielleicht Meridian,
vielleicht aber auch ein bisschen so. Kleines bisschen. Und ich, halt bei uns ist er ein bisschen näher in die Arbeit. Ja. Ich glaube, schon in der Mitte. Wir teilen beide sehr viele Eigenschaften. Ja, aber farblich identisch, also wirklich exakt identisch. Wir drei, also wirklich, wir werden ganz eng aneinander geschrieben. So, das Spannende ist, ich, also erstmal lernt man dann sehr viel über Farben, man kriegt ein PDF, ich habe, es dauert zwei Wochen, ich fand es super, super interessant, so und dann kommen ganz viele Seiten über Farbnerdheiten, so und dann kommt meine Seite und also ich habe mich darauf sehr gefreut, weil ich habe wirklich die Effekte firsthand gesehen. Und es gibt halt die verschiedenen Typen, es ist aufgeteilt in welche Farben man trägt. X-Achse ist from deep to light, also von dunkel bis nach hell, was steht einem. Und dann gibt es die Y-Achse, die ist von unten soft bis oben clear. Okay? Okay. Und dann gibt es… Soft, clear. Soft und clear. Und dann gibt es warme Farben und cool Colors. Und der Hälfte… Das ist ein dreidimensionaler Graph, oder was? Nicht ganz. Und zwar hat man jetzt der Einfachheit halber unterteilt in die vier Jahreszeiten. Und zwar gibt es den Spring. Da gibt es Clear Spring, True Spring, Light Spring. Diese ganzen Leute können warme Farben vertragen. Was wäre jetzt zum Beispiel eine warme Farbe? Braun oder orange. Also herbstliche Farben? Nee, nicht unbedingt. Es gibt auch Orange, das finde ich eine typische typische Frühlingsfarbe, aber es gibt auch Blautöne, die natürlich je mehr Rot die drin haben, auch wärmer werden. Es gibt warmes Lila, aber es gibt auch sehr kaltes Lila, wenn mehr Blau drin ist. Okay. So, dann gibt es cool, also kühle Farben und dann sei gesagt vorneweg, schwarz steht eigentlich nur True Winters. Also zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel für True Winter wäre zum Beispiel Timothy Chalamet oder auch Demi Moore. Also so Leute, die sehr blatt... Oder Hermann Göring. Also man muss ja... Aber Fickler. Man muss sagen muss sagen, also ... Albert Speer hingegen, True Autumn. Absolut. So, und dann kommt man langsam, wird ja gezeigt, was man selber ist. Und bei mir kam dann, da muss man diese furchtbaren Bilder einreichen mit verschiedenen farbigen T-Shirts. Die, hoffentlich sieht die niemand. Jetzt, ich sehe es vor, ist halt auf Englisch, aber wir kommen durch. Wir kommen gemeinsam durch. Ich würde die Bilder gerne sehen. Können wir die nicht zumindest für unsere Clubmitglieder verfügbar machen? Ja, ich glaube, die können über meine Schulter, können die Clubmitglieder auf meinem Bildschirm und diesen toten Blick. Umso lustiger finde ich, was der Text über mich sagt, weil man wirklich so tote Bilder über sich, wie so biometrische Bilder macht, wo sehr viel Gesicht ist und ein bisschen Shirt. Man muss ein blaues Shirt anziehen, grünes Shirt und dann auch pink oder so. Und nur kurz, ist das komplett automatisiert oder sitzen da in Mailand irgendwelche Modedesigner und schauen sich das dann so, ich stelle mir so gross ausgedruckte Fotos vor, wo die dann drüber sitzen mit ihren Turtlenecks und dann da sitzen und sagen, no, no, clear, he is
a clear autumn guy.
Look at those eyes, look at those cold,
fresh cold eyes. He is giving me the chills,
guys. He is giving me the real chills.
So, that's good shit, that's good German
shit. So stelle ich mir die vor, oder
ist es einfach nur Horde Inder.
Also, das ist die Frage, nee, es ist wirklich eine Frau,
Anushka Rees heißt die, ich kann die an der
Stelle sagen, ist nicht bezahlt, ich finde die super, ich folge der auch bei Instagram jetzt, die macht da sehr viel Farbtheorie und so und dann macht so kleine Quizzes, wo man erkennen kann, ist das eine warme Farbe, ist das eine kalte Farbe.
Also ich finde die toll, also Shoutout.
Es ist so zwischen super elaboriert und Kindergarten.
Ja, Farben.
Kindergarten, wo du einfach, die Ente ist gelb, der Elefant ist grau und irgendwie, dreissig Jahre später kommt das alles nochmal, wo du dachtest, ich dachte, das hätte ich alles geschafft, da wäre ich durch. Als Kind lernt man relativ schnell, wenn ich Knetenfarben für sich alle cool, je mehr ich mit Knete spiele und Sand reinkomme und andere Farben, es wird braun und am Ende habe ich keine Lust mehr. Da denkt man so, ah, Farben, I got it, I got it. Und jetzt kommt alles wieder.
Und ja, so, es ist tatsächlich von ihr nicht automatisiert, sondern sie schreibt individuelle Texte.
Da ich jetzt mehrere dieser Sheets kenne, weiß ich das auch, und sie guckt sich Bilder von ihr an, beschreibt Dinge, macht Pfeile in dein Gesicht und sagt dir, was die Besonderheiten sind.
Initial impression.
Looking at your delicate soft complexion, I immediately know you are a summer type.
Complexion ist Hautfarbe, sowas in der Richtung.
A true summer or a soft summer. Your skin tone backs me up. It's muted with a cool undertone. Da geht es dann darum, bei manchen, wenn man die Adern sieht, gehen die ein bisschen mehr ins Grün, bei manchen gehen die ein bisschen mehr ins Blau. Das sorgt für die warmen, manche haben warmere Hauptfarben. Wir sind cool as fuck, mach dir gar keine Sorgen, brauchst dir gar it. You are so cold, thereaturated look of a soft type. My verdict, you're a summer type that is characterized by softness as soft summer. Soft summer, Stefan! Da haben wir doch schon den Namen für deine Autobiografie, soft summer. Ich natürlich direkt absolut sauer. Mir gefällt der Name nicht. Warum? Es gibt den true summer type. Das ist Du bist ein Softie-Summer-Typ. Aber Soft Summer! Warum nicht Masculine? Nee, Soft Summer. Hart Hot Summer. Nee, du bist so ein bisschen wie so eine Luftmatratze am Pool. So weich und irgendwie so... Ich bin wie so ein Sommertag, der so den Shark gejumpt hat. Genau, wo man schon keinen Bock mehr hat. Es ist schon zu schwitzig. Oder zu kalt. So ein kalter Sommertag, der so cool ist, als wäre es noch Sommer. Aber es ist so viel zu kalt und man sieht schon so eine Jacke mit. Man weiß nicht, sieht man die Jacke noch mit oder nicht und es ist bewölkt. Was ist für ein Tag? Interessant, Soft Summer, auch der Kannibale von Rotenburg. Und ein Richemland, genau. So, dann erklärt sich so ein paar Sachen mit so Feilen. Ich habe Aqua Ice, das ist meine Farbe.
Also blau? Ja, so grün, so blau-grün-Mischmasch, auch ein bisschen grau. So, jetzt kriegt man dann eine Tabelle und das ist natürlich auch übrigens, auch Soft Summers sind zum Beispiel Jennifer Aniston oder auch Rihanna. Nur damit ihr da Bescheid wisst. Aber auch Mark Ruffalo, was ich lustig finde. Echt ein Kutscher. Und Osama Bin Laden. Das ist ein guter Gesellschaft. Genau, ja. Rihanna? Ja, Rihanna ist auch Soft Summer. Aber jetzt, also ne, komplett vorbehaltlos. Es geht nicht um die Hautfarbe. Es geht um die Kontraste und die Farben, die deine, die das, es geht nicht nur um, deswegen haben wir gerade drei Dimensionen aufgemacht, du machst jetzt wieder zwei Dimensionen auf. Es geht um den Kontrastlevel. Du, ich bin komplett eindimensional unterwegs, mach dir da gar keine Vorstellung. Ja genau, wir waren gerade schon mal weiter, wir waren gerade bei drei Dimensionen und du klappst langsam wieder die Würfel zusammen. Aber spannend, dass sowohl Rihanna als auch du die gleichen Typ haben und die gleichen Farben tragen sollst. Das heißt, eigentlich musst du jetzt bei Red Carpet ein besonderes Augenmerk auf Rihanna legen. Ihr könnt gerne Bilder von Rihannas Outfits posten, einfach um Stefan Tietze Ideen zu geben, was ja ihm auch gut stehen würde. Jetzt muss ich dazu sagen, Red Carpets stehen generell nicht so viel, mir nicht. Stimmt, du bist auf rotem Teppich, bist ja komplett verloren. Rot ist so schlimm. So, jetzt ist es super spannend. Welche Farben stehen mir? Und da zeigt mir das doch ein bisschen, dass das PDF ein bisschen automatisiert ist. Zumindest dann nach dem Resultat Soft Summer, weil einer der Sätze ist, you're the queen of grace. Das finde ich wäre mein besseres Name für meine Biografie. Ich muss gerade überlegen, Soft Summer oder Queen of Grace. The Queen of Grace. The Queen of the Grace. Also Stefan Thiel ist the Queen of Grace. Grossartig. Ich bin the Queen of Grace und spannend, weil ich habe immer viel Grau getragen, mag ich. Also war es komplett sinnlos? Ja, Schwarz zum Beispiel steht den wenigsten. Schwarz will ich nur True Winters, Weiss auch nicht, alle sehen ein bisschen blass aus, ein bisschen verloren in Weiss. Ja, einfach weil es nicht dem Farbspektrum... Ja gut, es ist unser Merch nur mal schwarz. Das habe ich auch gedacht. Das ist natürlich ein Riesen, Riesen, Riesenproblem, weil wir natürlich... Wir müssen neue Schiffe aus dem Suezkanal bestellen. Ja, oder halt einfach oft waschen. Also da geht die Farbe schnell raus. Macht euch da keine Ordnung. Das habe ich auch gedacht, bei Grau ist es natürlich cool. Einfach wer will waschen und dann wird es ja irgendwann ... Alles wird immer grau, egal was es ist. Oder braun. Ja, und meine Farben sind halt, also alles, was in Richtung Burgund, Lila, Flieder geht. Ich brauche nur kalte Farben. Flieder, was ist ein Flieder für eine Farbe? Lavender, Lavender. Was ist Flieder für eine Farbe? Flieder, so lila, lilerich. Okay, lilerich. Aber nicht Burgund, Burgund ist... Also du bist Burgund und Lila. Guck mal, ich zeige dir mal meine Farben. Mhm. Und das, dafür macht man es ja. Okay, ich sehe da viel Pink oben, unten ist ein bisschen Grün mit dabei, in der Mitte Blau. Aber alles kalte Farben. Was fehlt, sind knallige Farben, Rot, da ist ein bisschen mittelig, hast du was Türkises drin, was ein bisschen knallig ist, aber ansonsten... Ja, knallige Farben sind gar nicht gut für mich. Ich bin ein Soft Summer. Soft Summer verträgt gar keine knalligen Farben. Knallige Farben sind für mich schädlich, weil die meine Softness, meinen Soft-Typ zu overbearing. Ah, verstehen. Du würdest quasi untergehen unter deinem T-Shirt. Also das T-Shirt würde dich überdecken, überstrahlen quasi. Richtig. Du kannst nicht mit deinem T-Shirt mithalten. Also wenn du jetzt ein knallrotes T-Shirt tragen würdest, dann kämst du nicht mehr mit deinem T-Shirt.
Du hast noch nie so viel Energie ever in diesem Podcast. Plötzlich kannst du nicht eröffnen.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe mir ja zum Beispiel das Deutschland-Trikot jetzt bei der EM gekauft, das Pinke.
Richtig, ja.
Das ist die schlimmste Farbe für mich.
Moment, die ist doch da dabei oder nicht. Da sind doch solche Pink-Töne dabei.
Ja, aber again, Soft Summer, die kalt,
jetzt ist Pink kalt, super kalt,
aber es ist viel zu knallig.
Pink ist kalt, ey,
Leute, ich bin da noch nicht tief drin,
aber es ist anscheinend eine Wissenschaft für sich.
Folgt ja mal bei, da kannst du die
Quizzes machen, ich dreck da auch noch nicht so viel,
aber wir kommen da langsam rein.
Es gibt so ein paar,
genau, also heute habe ich mich zum Beispiel, generell, also meine ganze Garderobe kann ich jetzt weggeben. Die ist jetzt komplett. Aber die Frage ist, wem gibst du die jetzt? Weil du müsstest ja jetzt eigentlich, eigentlich müsste man in sein Instagram-Profil reinschreiben, was für ein Typ man ist, damit man genau farblich irgendwie Leuten auch weitergeben kann. Eigentlich müsste die gesamte Population einmal diesen Test machen und dann wird Kleidung einfach nur rotiert. Von Leuten, die es brauchen, zu dem geben. Niemand kauft die Modeindustrie, liegt brach, endlich, was ja eh schon mein Ziel ist, seit 2008. Und dann haben eigentlich alle das, was sie brauchen, ohne dass jemand was Neues kaufen muss. Egal. Aber ich meine, das wird sich ja auch ändern, oder? Ist das nicht auch Moden unterlegen? Weil es gibt ja auch Mode, oder nicht? In fünf Jahren ist das ja anders. Man sieht seine Farben und es sind so 50 Farben. Und man sieht die jetzt und denkt sich, das soll ich jetzt anziehen. Und dann laufe ich aber jetzt neuerdings durch die Welt, auch online, mal metaphorisch gesprochen, laufe ich jetzt mit diesen Farben herum und sehe dann doch sehr viele Modestücke oder weiß ich nicht, da habe ich so Vintage nach so Jacken geguckt, die dann irgendwie diese Farben haben, man findet dann doch relativ viel. Kann man das so dranhalten, sein Handy mit diesem Farbding und ich finde das total super, weil du bist ja erschlagen, die Modewelt bietet dir so viel an und ich habe da keine Ahnung von. Ja, klar. Ich interessiere mich dafür, aber ich habe keine Ahnung davon. Vor allem, du bist ja ein riesen Accessoire-Typ, ne, also man sieht dich ja eigentlich nie, man sieht dich ja nie mit leeren Händen, du hast irgendwie dann Eis in der Hand und da kannst du jetzt natürlich auch keinen Schlumpf mehr essen. Ja, Cactus Green. Cactus Green, du musst jetzt Cactus-Eis essen, ob du willst oder nicht, wenn du den, also du willst den Sommer rocken, Queen of Summer, sehe ich vor. Queen of the Greys. Queen of Soft Summer. Queen of Grey Summer. Queen of Soft Summer. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt eigentlich auch nicht mehr Schlumpf essen als Eisbecher, weil es weisst sich total mit deinen Farben. Du musst jetzt leider Kaktus essen, was du hasst. Du hasst den Geschmack von Kaktus. Ja, hasse ich. Aber farblich, muah. Ja genau, es passt halt sowieso mit dem Gesicht. Du isst das Eis ja auch nicht, du lässt es einfach nur in deiner Hand schmelzen, um auf den Fotos dann cool auszusehen. Dieser Pulli zum Beispiel, der, das würde ich sagen, geht als True Grey oder Stone Grey durch, deswegen ist der gut. Ich habe oft einen helleren an, den kann ich jetzt auch weg, verbrennen kann ich den jetzt. Die grosse Kleiderverbrennung. Ja, der kommt weg. Genau, Heinrich Hebel. So, also dann zum Beispiel Blautöne, auch ins hellere. Generell manche Sachen finde ich spannend, die habe ich mir schon gekauft. Ich habe mir mal so ein Shirt gekauft, wo ich dachte, das steht mir gut. Gar nicht meine Farbe, so ein Sage Green. Ja. Und dann sehe ich es jetzt, ist einfach eine Farbe, die mir offensichtlich nachgewiesenerweise steht. Also das ist super spannend und dann sieht man auch, wie ich finde, tatsächlich die Unterschiede. Also hier gibt es so ein paar Bilder. Guck mal hier auf dem ersten Bild. Du siehst wirklich, das sind Soft Summers und du siehst Weiss, was es mit der Haut macht und dann so ein klares Grau, was es mit der Haut macht. Boah, aber ich denke mir, bei so einem Foto spielen da nicht so viele Aspekte mit rein. Also man kann so unterschiedlich aussehen auf einem Foto. Welche Beleuchtung, welche Filter, welches Color Grading und so. Das sind ja so feine Unterschiede, oder? Also ich hab ja viel... Aber du siehst ja auch, du willst ja auch sagen, dass es in manchen Sachen besser aus ist, als in anderen Sachen. Jetzt weiss man dann als Laie nicht, woran das liegt. Aber schau mal bitte, was das Braunton mit der Hautfarbe macht. Und dann trägt man so ein kaltes Braun und das sind jetzt auch alle soft, sagen wir mal, ich bin da sehr drin, ich bin sehr davon begeistert, weil tatsächlich ist es ja einfach, also Farben und wie die zueinander stehen, ist ja nachgewiesen, also was es mit einem macht, das ist ja schon, da gibt es ja eine Grundlage, jetzt muss man dem nicht folgen, wenn man sich jetzt anzieht, jeder kann machen, was er oder sie will.
Ich finde es für mich eine coole Form, einfach ein cooles Raster, in dem ich mich jetzt bewege. Du kannst jetzt, wenn jetzt mal wieder jemand auf Reddit kommentiert, oh, wer hat Stefan denn das Outfit rausgelegt, totaler Griff ins Klo, kannst du sagen, Seitdem er Mann ihn ausrüstet, geht's mir grad mit ihm.
Kannst du sagen, nein, objektiv wissenschaftlich steht mir das und ich sehe aus wie ein cool Gentile Stag. Ja, Big Cock Stag sehe ich aus mit diesem Outfit. Du kannst es jetzt objektiv angehen. Finde ich gut? Also ich finde es krass, ich finde es beeindruckend. Mir hat es sehr viel Spaß gemacht, das zu lesen und jetzt noch ein bisschen die ich war jetzt lange nicht zu Hause, jetzt bin ich wieder zu Hause, ich werde meinen Kleiderschrank komplett umstrukturieren gemäss meiner Farben. Ihr werdet mich hier nicht mehr in Weiss sehen und wenn, dann erinnert mich und sagt Stefan, Weiss macht dich blass. Weiss macht dich blass und fahl und aschig und kaputt. Ich glaube, ich habe nur Angst, dass wir halt weiter auseinander driften, ne, also du warst sonst, also ich sag mal, optisch jetzt einfach ansprechender fürs Auge, ne, ich bin kantiger und ich habe jetzt natürlich das Gefühl, dass wenn wir noch weiter auseinander driften, wird es natürlich schwierig, also, ne, für Videoproduktion, dass man einfach fast schon so einen 3D-Effekt hat, dass einer total blau, der andere total rot ist, dass das fast schon so ein flimmeriges Gefühl ist, weil eigentlich habe ich mich immer schon an dir festgeklammert, immer wenn du einen Schritt modisch nach vorne gemacht hast, habe ich versucht, hinterher zu hecheln. Ah, okay. Um die Balance zu halten. Um die Balance zu halten, habe ich mich nochmal nach hinten geworfen und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, die Balance stimmt irgendwie nicht mehr zwischen uns. Weil ich fünf nach vorne mache und du hinterher rennst. Richtig, genau. Ich bin links abgebogen und bin jetzt wo ganz anders unterwegs, weil, wie gesagt, ich musste leider einen Pulli wegschmeißen, weil ich scharfe Soße draufgeschmiert habe. Das heißt, das ist halt so mein modisches Niveau und ich habe das Gefühl, du ziehst davon und ich bin nicht mehr im Windschatten. Ich bin nicht mehr in deinem Windschatten. Ich verstehe ja auch, du interessierst dich ja auch nicht so doll wie ich, wir haben andere Interessen, ich finde das okay, ich habe auch keine Ahnung von Mode, ich finde es so teilweise spannend, ich mag Farben jetzt auch, es passt auch in meine Malphase, wo man lernt, was mischt man mit was, um was zu ergeben. Hat das denn deine Kunst beeinflusst, jetzt diese Farbanalyse? Weil stehen dir deine Bilder oder gerade nicht und was sagt das aus über deine Kunst? So, und da fängt man jetzt mal an, drüber nachzudenken. So, und da fängt dieser Podcast an, Dreisatzpodcast zu werden. So, und jetzt machen alle aus. Ja. Das war das Ende des Podcasts-Sufus. Wenn man sich jetzt fragt, wo ist es auseinander getrifftet, wo haben wir die Hörer verloren, was kommt diese Stelle? Das war genau dieser Punkt, Hälfte. Aber gibt es jetzt gewisse Regeln für dich? Ja, kalte Farben, nur kalte Farben. Okay, aber ich meine es ist eher sowas wie Lebensführungsregel, weil so ein Studio ist jetzt raus. Oder weil wenn du jetzt dein Tint verändern würdest. Die Farbe, meine Hautfarbe hat geringen Einfluss nur darauf. Okay. Es geht um die Sättigung.
Manche haben so, Es geht nicht um deine Augenfarbe. Auch. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel eine Sonnenbrille trägst, dann ist es ja wieder komplett disbalanced, alles ist wieder neu gewirbelt, die Knete drückt sich aneinander, sind da Haare dran, ist das Kupel. Aber meine Haarfarbe ist ja gleich... Aha, zum Beispiel. So, wenn ich die, zum Beispiel. Dürftest du jetzt deine Haarfarbe nicht mehr färben? Doch, da steht drin, welche. Oh gut, dann können wir da doch mal reinkommen. Das würde mich mal interessieren. Was sind potenzielle zukünftige Haarfarben für Stefan Tietze? Auch gerne hier mal das eine oder andere Photoshop-Tool anwerfen. Also Make-up soll ich Bright and Intense Colors vermeiden. Also ich soll roten Lippenstil vermeiden und lieber eher Soft Definition, Berry Lips zum Beispiel. Ja, okay. Ich soll auch too much contrast, also was soll ich, Augenumrandung, schwarz, Lidschatten vermeiden. Kann ich bei mir sehen? Billy Joe Armstrong von Green Day, der Sänger. Ja. Schwarze Haare, knallige Farben, da macht es Sinn. Gibt dem halt einfach Lidschatten, bei mir glaube ich nicht, ich soll das vermeiden. So, jetzt haben wir hier Hair-Color. Also, genau, meine Naturhaarfarbe, so Aschblond, dunkelblond. Ich kann aber auch Neutral Medium Brown vertragen. Ich kann auch Neutral Dark Brown vertragen. Darkest Brown Silber und Natural Grey. Okay, Silber fand ich hier noch am spannendsten. The Silver Queen. Könnte natürlich auch noch rauskommen, wenn du dich entscheidest, die Haarfarbe zu ändern. Okay, finde ich gut. Interessante Aussichten für die nächsten Phasen von Stefan Tietze, die dann vielleicht auch mit anderen Haarfarben begleitet werden. Ganz ehrlich, ich finde die Anushka Bres ist in Berlin, ist eine Deutsche, glaube ich, also ich wohne zumindest in Berlin. Wenn ihr da Interesse daran habt, die macht das alleine, die bringt cool Farben bei. Ich finde das mega geil. Ich finde es gut. Warum ich das so toll finde, ist Menschen mit einem Nischeninteresse, generell Nerds, die sich in irgendeine Richtung brachial durch Wissenswand und Wissenswand geworfen haben,
bis sie einfach so in eine Richtung gemarschiert sind. Ich finde das toll.
Menschen, die sich so einfach ein Interesse schnappen, weil das bin ich nicht.
Bin ich überhaupt nicht. Ich habe ganz viele Nischeninteressen und ich verliere das Interesse,
sobald es tiefer geht und ich merke dann den Krüger-mässig, oh, da ist aber noch viel nachzuholen. Aber sie ist ihrem Thema treu geblieben und hat da viel Erfahrung. Und dann natürlich muss man auch sagen, professionelle Stylisten und so, die die Stars ausstatten, die wissen ja auch immer, was sie machen. Ja, aber was du vorhin angemerkt hast, finde ich ganz interessant, ist natürlich der Red Carpet mit seiner Röte schon relativ viele Outfits wahrscheinlich vordefiniert und man sagen kann, okay, das ist ein gewisser Red Carpet Look, weil das sich ja auch anpassen muss. Ich habe mir schon genau überlegt, in Zürich gibt es den Green Carpet beim Zürcher Filmfest, da muss ich halt da hin. Gut, da kannst du ja auch in der Post-Production noch viel machen, also grün kriegst du immer raus. Nee, weil die Oscars zum Beispiel... Ist nicht, nee, gar nicht deins. Ja, oder dann, also klar, wenn es hart auf hart kommt... Ist aber auch eine gute Ausrede, ne? Also ich will immer Ausreden sammeln in meinem Leben und wenn jemand sagt, ey, sag mal, jetzt Met Gala, kommst du vorbei? Und ich sag so, boah, der Teppich beißt sich leider mit meiner Complexion, total, da kann man nicht leider nicht rumkommen Ach ja, verstehe ich ja total. Also finde ich gut, dass man hier so ein bisschen mehr Ausreden im Köchert. Jetzt würde ich mir wünschen, dass du das auch machst. Ja. Und dann möchte ich, dass du... Ich habe aber leider, glaube ich, die verlangten T-Shirts nicht wirklich. Ich habe, wenn es heißt blaues T-Shirt, ich habe einen Pullover mit einer Gans drauf, mit einer Sprechblase und da steht drin Wow. Genau. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das passt als Analysefoto, ob man da drauf anspringt. Genau, wir gucken mal rein, lustige T-Shirts nicht tragen. Ah, okay. Lieber nicht tragen. Medium Jokes, with a medium complexion. Da seid ihr hier schon richtig. Moderately funny, not too funny. Also ich, diese PDF liebe ich.
Geil. Ja, und hier zum Beispiel, I especially love these colors on you. Cactus green, ash gray, soft burgeon, deep teal, so ein Petrol. Was ist los mit Cactus? Ich habe das Gefühl, irgendjemand versucht, aktuell Kakteen zu pushen. Ich habe letztens ein gewisses Sortiment an Softdrinks gesehen und habe da gesehen, Peach, Lemon, Pfirsich, so die Klassiker und dann aber Kaktusfrucht. Und da dachte ich mir, bei mir potenzielle Softdrink-Geschmäcker ist Kaktusfrucht auf 86. Aber liegt es daran, dass du, weil du nicht genau weißt, was es ist, Aussetzung?
Absolut, absolut. Hast du, wenn ich
jetzt sage Kaktusfrucht, hast du einen Geschmack im Mund?
Ja, den vom Kaktuseis,
also Ananas. Aber das
Kaktuseis schmeckt nicht nach Kaktus. Eben.
Du meinst den das Kaktus? Genau.
Hat Generationen von Kindern in die Irre geführt,
dass so Kaktus schmeckt, vorgegaukelt,
dass Kaktus köstlich ist. Und britzelt.
Und dann denkst du, ein köstlicher Kaktus, bist du irgendwo in Kansas, denkst dir, das ist ein köstlicher Kaktus-Kansas und dann kriegst du am Ende nur Nadeln im Mund. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich glaube, irgendjemand da draußen, das neue Superfood soll Kaktus sein. Ich glaube, irgendwann kommt raus, dass irgendein Kaktus-Produzent irgendwie ganz lange schon subtil versucht, die Industrie zu beeinflussen. Ich mag aber auch zum Beispiel, und da setze ich mich jetzt wahrscheinlich in die Nesseln, in die Kapitellen. In die Stacheln. Ich mag Kokoswasser zum Beispiel auch gar nicht. Wirklich? Ja, da bist du jetzt aktiv in Nesseln. Bin ich jetzt in den Nesseln gesetzt? Da kommst du so schnell nicht mehr raus. Habe ich mir jetzt in den Nesseln gesetzt? Da kommst du so schnell nicht mehr raus. Das war's. Ja? Das war's. Vorraut dich jetzt in den Nesseln? Ja, ja, ja. Du ertrinkst am Kaktuswasser. Aber es gibt ja dieses Berliner, diese Dosen, diese schicken Dosen, wo so Kokoswasser drin ist. Und es sieht so toll aus, es trinken so hippe Leute. Da habe ich es einmal probiert und dachte mir, was trinken die hippen Leute. Was ich früher sehr gerne getrunken habe, ist Kaktusmilch mit Pfefferminz-Sirup. Pfefferminz-Sirup generell sehr schön. Kaktusmilch? Kokosmilch. Mit Pfefferminz. Also Kokus-Pfefferminz mit Kaktus-Kokos. So, jetzt haben wir es. So, das ist sehr frisch. Ich mag generell, Grün ist, glaube ich, meine geschmacklich gute Farbe. Sehr gut. Man kann natürlich auch nochmal einen Knospentest machen. Sehr gut. Schneid dir mal drei Geschmacksknospen ab und schick sie mir in einen Briefumschlag. Und ich sag dir genau, welche Farben dir gut schmecken, in welche Richtung es da geht. Tatsächlich bin ich gerade auf einer Art kulinarischen Revolution, weil ich hinterfrage aktuell so meine Einstellungen zu gewissen Gerichten. Man sagt dir immer, das mag ich nicht, das esse ich nicht gerne. Aber man isst es dann zehn Jahre lang nicht teilweise. Und die Palette hat sich verändert, der Körper hat sich verändert, man ist fett geworden, man ist langsam geworden, man ist zägen, man ist eh alles egal. Und dann denkt man es neu und denkt sich, warum habe ich das die letzten zehn Jahre nicht genossen eigentlich? Und für mich ganz neu entdeckt ist Mineralwasser. Ich habe ganz, ganz lange kein Mineralwasser genossen. Ja, Heinrich Himmler's Lieblingsgetränk. Ja, okay, aber jetzt gar nicht. Nee, ich meine nur. Nee, aber darum ging es gar nicht in der Hinsicht, sondern schön Kasten Mineralwasser zu Hause, ich immer nur Leitungswasser, immer schön meine ranzige, ekelhafte, schon lange hätte zum Pfand gebracht werden müssen, alte Plastikflasche, immer wieder neu befüllt mit Leitungswasser. Und Mineralwasser waren immer die Leute mit ihrem Drücker da. Also das war für mich das Komplizierteste für den geringsten Wert. Also du musst dir so eine CO2-Kartusche unter der Hand an der Kasse, dann musst du zum Edeka dir eine ... Was? Ich bra ich brauche noch eine CO2-Bist. Stimmt, bist du warm? Hey, wie lange gehe ich hier einkaufen? Hast du deine Kartusche dabei? Wie lange kaufe ich hier? Hast du deine 12 Kilo schwere Stahlbeton-Kartusche dabei? Ja, bleib ganz ruhig, ich bin nicht dabei. Ja, dann hieb sie mir mal rüber. Hier. Okay ist eine neue Die ist nicht schwerer, komischweise. Keine Sorge, du kannst damit gut zwei, drei Liter Mineralwasser machen. Kein Problem, okay. Alles klar, macht 600 Euro. Und du kaufst CO2. Das ist zu kompliziert. Dann schleppst du das durch die Gegend, dann hast du es zu Hause und dann nimmst du Leidungswasser und dann so bfff, bfff, irgendwie nochmal explodiert alles, alles wacht auf, die ganze Siedlung wacht auf. Und dann hast du so dieses schäbige Ding oder du musst Kästen schleppen, war mir immer zu nervig, wo ich mir dachte, dann hol dir doch Cola, eine Mate oder so. Aber jetzt Mineralwasser, ich hab's mir wieder reingegönnt. Sehr gut. Und ich... Man kann es auch abspice mit ein bisschen Zitronen. Nein, nein, niemals, niemals, niemals, Fauxpas, Nessel, Nessel-Alarm, Nessel-Alarm. Du bist tief in den Nessel. Du wirst jetzt in den Nessel reingefallen. Du bist gar nicht aufgestanden, du hast gar nicht versucht aufzustehen, als du in den Nessel. Ich rufe einfach aus dem Nessel, mach Zitrone rein. Du legst immer noch in den Nesseln. Du legst immer noch in den Nesseln. Moment, oh, du kugelst den Hang runter, unten sind noch mehr Nesseln, unten sind noch mehr Nesseln, oh, okay, runter Nesseln.
Und es ist richtig lecker und es ist schön, weil du kannst es genießen, aber es ist auch britzlich, ich mag das richtig Harte, was so richtig die Kehle wegätzt, was da so richtig einmal durchwischt mit dem Magen. Wenn du Dinge beschreibst, die du magst, Beobachtung, ist es Selbstverletzung.
Ja, richtig.
Und zwar, wenn du von heißen Bädern, die du gerne nimmst, dich beschreibst, betonst du oft, wie heiß und wie eigentlich viel zu heiß und schmerzhaft. Und ich bin, Zitat, ich war durch, ich war durch wie eine reife Gans. Ich war gar. Ich war gar, Haut war rosig und zum Essen bereit. Also so sagst du das zum Beispiel. Genau, Kannibale von Rotenburg, ich bin deins. Und dann jetzt wiederum beim Wasser sagst du auch, ich mag es lieber, je mehr es mir wehtut. Frage, hast du vielleicht bei Genuss eine Selbstverletzende? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und warum rauchst du dann nicht? Definitiv, definitiv.
Ich will mir schaden, ich will, dass es wehtut, weil Schmerz und Genuss liegen ganz nah aneinander. Weil wenn es nicht wehtut, dann kannst du es ja unendlich viel genießen und dann ist es auch nicht mehr reizvoll so. Das ist ja das, wie wenn du irgendwie... Die Endlichkeit ist dir wichtig. Die Endlichkeit und auch das, keine Ahnung, wenn du jetzt was isst mit viel Kalorien, ist es auch so, okay, ich darf nicht so viel davon essen und dadurch wird es interessant. Und hier ist es eben einfach der Schmerz, dass du dir das nicht einfach literweise runterkekeln kannst, sondern einfach irgendwann die Kehle sagt. Zurück zum Verb, zurück zum Verb. Kegeln. Kegeln. Ne, Kegeln, ne, du hast ja noch Bronchien, oder? Hast du noch Bronchien? Ich habe noch mehrere Bronchien. Oder Mandeln? Ja. Was ist irgendein, das ist meine Vorstellung des Rachens, ist, da hängt eine Menge rum. Bronchien, Mandeln, Mandelsteine, Katerkompen und das ist halt irgendwas da. Und in einem Gespräch jemand sagt, ich habe meine Mandeln rausbekommen, ich habe meinen Gaumenzäpfchen rausbekommen. Alles stelle ich mir gleich vor, wie dieses Ding in... Adamsapfel, alles kehlig irgendwie Zeug, das ist einfach Salat. Aber ich stelle mir alles wie diesen Fropfen, der von oben herunterhängt in der Kehle vor.
Und wenn Comicfiguren schreien, dann wackelt der so.
Wenn so Werner so ganz laut schreit, auf was Schmerz, dann wackelt so dieses Ding da so noch drin.
Oder Bart.
Und das sind für mich diese Bowlingpins oder so, sehe ich da hinten.
Aber sag mal kurz, was habe ich denn rausbekommen? Die Pupillen.
Pupillen, Pupillen.
Du hast die Pupillen rausnehmen lassen. Jetzt hast du noch mehr Augenfarbe und kannst noch mehr tragen. Wie heißen die denn? Die Populetten. Ja, die. Die Populetten. So, die sind weg. Ja, die sind aber eher untenrum. Alles weg, alles rausgerissen. Nehmt mir alles raus. Pimpernellen. Die Pimpernellen. Und tatsächlich, seitdem Mineralwasser kümmere ich mir gerne rein rein, habe jetzt natürlich ein riesen Pfandproblem, ist klar. Hol dir doch den Aufstreamer. Nee, das will ich nicht. Warum denn nicht? Das ist demütigend. Nee, es gibt ja auch in Schick und Cool. Nee, aber ich habe Angst vor Druck. Alles, was so Gasflaschen und Propankataparenner und wirklich so Hochdruckdinger will ich nicht. Ich hatte schon wirklich panische Angst vor dem Hochdrucktopf. Dieser Drucktopf, wie heißt der? So dieser Kochtopf, wo enorm viel Druck drin ist. Ich lasse dich hängen. Lass mich zappeln. Du zappelst gerade wie wild. Heisskartuschenkottopfe. Hochdruck-Topf? Ja, Hochdruck-Topf.
Was macht er denn damit? Reiskocher?
Nee, da kannst du alles drin kochen.
Du kennst doch einen Hochdruck-Topf.
Airfryer. Mikrowelle.
Das wurde auch zum Beispiel
bei den
Bombenanschlägen beim Boston Marathon
haben die solche Töpfe benutzt.
So, nee, aber nur als,
aber gar nicht als, die Folge ist ein bisschen ein Downer, die Folge ist ein bisschen ein Downer, aber mir geht's ja, nee, mir geht's ja, ähm, mir geht's nur um die Beschreibung, du kannst damit auch herrliche Kartoffelgerichte machen, so, du musst damit nicht Anschläge, so, aber es geht auch. Weisst du, wer auch ein Soft Summer ist? Anders Breivik.
Soft. Aber weißt du, wer auch ein Soft Summer ist? Anders Breivik. Soft Summer. Ich habe einfach Angst vor Druck. Immer wenn ich, du kennst ja manchmal, wenn du mit dem Zug fährst, fährst du an diesen Lagerhöfen vorbei, wo einfach mal sechs, 16 Millionen Spulen liegen. So dass sie einfach, ach und denk mir, das sind noch nicht mal alle Spulen Deutschlands. Also es gibt noch viel mehr Spulen. Wenn du von Hamburg nach Köln fährst, kommst du ja an einem Bahnhof dabei, wo das ganz extrem der Fall ist. Ja genau, ganz viele Metallspulen. Ah, Spulhauptstadt? Ja, das ist meine Heimatstadt. Ah, die coolen Spulen aus Carmen. Du meinst diese braunen Spulen? Genau, diese Metallspulen, Drahtspulen, einfach Leitungen. Aber ich denke mir, das ist so viel Spule. Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich von diesen Lagerhöfen noch Hunderte in ganz Deutschland. Also die Gesamtmenge ist schwer zu erblicken. Und da fährst du dann vorbei und dann kommt so ein Gasflaschendepot mit unendlich und denk mir, oh, da ist so viel Druck drin. Gesamtdruck dieser Anlage pro Quadratmeter geht also 60 bar locker hoch, kein Problem. Und denk mir, es ist so viel Druck und ich werde wirklich ein bisschen nervös, weil ich denke mir immer, das ist so ein Domino-Day-Effekt, dass wenn eine Gasflasche so, ich kann nicht mehr, ich kann nicht mehr, hilf mir, ich kann nicht mehr, und dann die daneben auch, und dann fallen die alle um, so, und dann knallen die alle raus. Das ist der Film Oppenheimer, wo die ja im Grunde Angst hatten, dass es eine Kettenreaktion auslöst. Genau, ja, das ganze Universum verschluckt. Mach doch da den Film in kleinen, mini, kleinen als deutsche Adaption, dass du einfach Angst hast, dass dein Gasflaschendepot. So, ich habe Angst vor Druck, deswegen, um nochmal ganz zurückzuspulen, kam ich beim Tauchen auch nicht weiter. Ich war ja im Tauchkurs und habe da gelernt, wie man Finger bricht, Beine bricht, Knöchel bricht, also Gnick, Rückgrat, alles Rippen. Manchen, den du retten willst, musst du das Gnick brechen, sonst stirbst du. Genau, also manchmal, wenn die wirklich nerven, dann breche ich denen den Kopf. Ich übrigens. Dann breche ich denen einfach den Schädel kaputt. Was gerade mein neues Nischenhobby ist, ne, also wir machen den Folder auf. Wir haben den Folder Color Theory aufgemacht jetzt. Unterfolder, gerade meines Nischenhobbys. Du hast gerade zu schnell gescrollt. War das Porn?
In Farb Theory?
Ja, Farbporn. Wie Farbporn?
Was soll das sein?
Du meinst, wenn zwei
Komplementärfarben zusammen...
Naja, also...
Aber die Farben
werden
einfach gemischt und dann entsteht eine neue Farbe.
Ja, aber in den Farbformen wird das expliziter dargestellt.
Man will sagen, Orange besteht aus Gelb und Rot, aber das ist ja einfach, die werden einfach...
Gelb und Rot, ey.
Ja, aber die werden einfach gemischt, das ist ja nichts...
Da gibt es ja keine Erotik oder so.
Gelb trifft Rot. Rot macht eigentlich so eine Handwerksaufgabe bei Gelb. Und dann, klar, dann ist das ein bisschen länger da, blaust gerade raus auf Montage. Gibt es Teil zwei, genau und. Ja, ja, ja. Aber das ist einfach professionell, ist einfach ein Handwerker. Ja! Und damit so richtig gemischt einfach. Gemischt, also durchgerührt. Okay, jetzt kommen wir weiter. Boating Accidents. Oh, und das ist in Color Theory drin? Nur wenn man gerade sagt, mein Leben unterteilen wir in Farben. Grünes Boot und ein blaues Boot treffen sich am Suezkanal. Und das blaue Boot drückt das grüne Boot an die Wand und greift ihm in die Hose. Schön in die Schlange. Ich will nur sagen, das ist gerade mein neues Nischenhobby, ist Boating Accidents angucken. Idiots in Boats. Weil das Spannende an Booten ist, die Art Mensch, die Boote hat. Richtig, ja. Oft betrunken, superreicher, Drecksidioten. Nichts zu verlieren, kein Sinn für Objekt. Kein Gefühl für Material oder irgendwie, das hat jemand gemacht und ich muss auf Leute aufpassen. Und fühlt sich wie Jack Sparrow. Alle fühlen sich wie Jack Sparrow. Und die fahren reckless herum und bauen furchtbare Unfälle. Und sehen aus wie die grössten Vollidioten. Das ist meine wirklich Nischeninteresse. Die fahren ins Stege rein, weil die es nicht aushalten. Die sind alle betrunken und dann fahren die so weird. Und dann fährt ein Mast, fährt in die Brücke rein und der Mast bricht und man denkt, so ein Idiot. Weil oft sieht man bei Upsi-Pan-Show damals oder sowas, habe ich eigentlich nie gelacht, weil ich immer Mitleid hatte mit den Leuten. Oh ja. Wow, dann fällt das fette Kind beim Skifahren hin. Ich bin so, Leute, das ist wie uncool. Das war schlimmste Tag seines Lebens. Wurde auch noch gefilmt und jetzt muss er sich auch noch bei Ups-Die-Pannenshow filmen.
Kriegt er wahrscheinlich noch nicht mehr die 1.000 Mark.
Er kriegt dafür was? 500 Euro.
Vielleicht, wenn überhaupt.
Hat jemand die bekommen? Nein.
Und bei denen denke ich mir, alle haben das verdient, dann tut das auch nicht weh.
Und dann gibt es ja dieses fantastische Video von diesen vielen Leuten auf dem Boot, was vorhin so fix gefilmt ist.
Die hin- und herschlackern, ja. Es wird immer ein bisschen schlimmer. Und das Video ist wirklich wie so jemand, der so einen Volume-Regler auftritt. Und die schlackern immer mehr hin und hin, bis alle aus dem Boot fallen. Da kann ich nicht ganz laut drüber lachen. Ich muss auch sagen, solche Unfallvideos sind immer bei mir so zwischen, oh, zieht sich alles zusammen und super lustig. Und ich finde, je je mehr Spaß die Leute im Moment des Unfalls haben, desto lustiger wird es wieder für mich. Also wenn die so Sonnenbrille, Bikini, Drink, Party und dann Crash, das ist für mich tendenziell eher lustiger. Und das aufboden ist man, glaube ich, eher selten jetzt wirklich deprimiert. Jetzt kommt unser Farbkreis umgemünzt auf Humor, weil wir haben ja drei Dimensionen im Humor. Es gibt von ungefährlicher Humor, der niemandem wehtut, bis Anthony Jeselnik ist alles dabei, das ist die eine Dimension, das andere ist dann auch noch sowas wie Empathie, wie geht's den Leuten im Video, ist zum Beispiel ein, wie nennt man das dann? Also ich kann nicht lachen, wenn der sich wirklich weh getan hat. Richtig, genau. Wie nennt man dann sowas? Stringer genommen fällt es auch ein bisschen in die erste Kategorie. Aber ich wäre dafür, dass wir einen Kreis machen für Humor. Und bei dir ist natürlich... Kreis? Boah, jetzt... Was? Eine Kugel, eine Kugel, eine S. Ich bin ein bisschen müde einfach gerade, nach diesen ganzen Farbsachen, die ich mir vorstellen musste, weil es ist leider ein auditives Medium. Ich musste mir die Farben nur vorstellen, das hat mich schon mal angestrengt. Und jetzt werde ich langsam müde, weil du von Kreisen in ... Ich denke von Kreisen in dreidimensionalen Raum, also denk an eine Kem und da ist ein Kreistreten.
Also denk an eine Kugel.
Aber eine Kugel in einem dreidimensionalen. Nein, Kugel ist eine dreidimensional.
Und wir haben einmal, sagen wir mal, provokanter Humor zu Soft Humor.
Wir haben Empathie ist die zweite Achse, was ist die dritte Achse?
Wo ist Donald Duck?
Also wo ist, also wo?
Nein, Einfachheit und Complexion.
Einfachheit und Hautfarbe.
Okay, jetzt bin ich an Bord. Complexity. Also Einfachheit, Donald Duck rutscht auf der Banane aus, andere Richtung ist ein Mathematiker-Joke, den die Leute verstehen mit sehr viel Grundwissen. Richtig. Und jetzt Donald Duck rutscht auf der Banane auf, wäre ein sehr simpler Witz, der von
der Empathie auch recht niedrig ist, also ich muss mir keine Sorgen machen, dass Donald Duck sich wehgetan hat, weil Donald Duck existiert nicht mehr. So, und da muss ich mir keine Sorgen machen. Weil er verstorben ist in einem Furchtbar. Genau, er ist verstorben bei dem Boston Marathon. Auf der Provokanz-Ebene geht, oder?
Also Enter rutscht auf Banane aus.
Also auf allen drei Skalen niedrig.
Okay.
So, und jetzt gibt es auch noch die Zeit.
Ganz links unten ist diese.
Gerade dein Beispiel, dein Boston Marathon-Witz.
Wäre nicht so lustig gewesen,
einen Tag vor Form.
Das stimmt. Ja ja das ist richtig das ist eine Treff und Analyse ich habe auch Mitleid mit dem armen Comedian, der 9-11-Joke am 8. September gemacht, nein am 10. September, doch am 10. September gemacht hat. Schreit ja rum in seinem eigenen Witz. Also, das ist wichtig. Zeit, Timing, Witze über 9-11, vor 9-11. Die können nicht vierdimensional sein, Stefan, es funktioniert nicht. Witze jetzt über 9-11 können lustig sein, Witze an 9-11, terrible, Witze vor 9-11, verdächtig. Sehr verdächtig. Aber für eine kleine Gruppe Menschen sehr lustig. Für die Entführer extrem lustige Insider vor 9-11, danach ist das auch weg. Leben nicht mehr, die meisten. Ja, das stimmt. Rest in hell Hell. Oh, Jesus, diese Folge ist fucking weird. Es ist auch Summer-Folge, die steht nicht jedem, weil ich finde, man könnte genauso zu dem Farbtest, könnte man ja auch einen Podcast-Test machen. Wir kriegen immer ganz viele Nachrichten, hey, was könnte ich den Stadt einen Podcast-Ufo hören? Und da gehen uns dann langsam auch die Empfehlungen aus, ehrlich gesagt.
Nein, Roti, stopp. Weißt du, unser Problem ist auch, wir können Marketing nicht.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Wenn du jetzt sowas sagst, wir kriegen viele Nachrichten, wo Leute nach anderen Podcasts fragen,
aber spannend, dass das aussagt.
Ja.
Sie mögen den Podcast nicht,
aber sie vertrauen auch irgendwie
dem Geschmack.
Sie können
alle anderen fragen, welchen Podcast
sie lieber hören.
Da bräuchten wir auch Hilfe, dass wir eine Analyse machen,
vielleicht von den Ohren,
von Gehörkamera,
ich habe eine Ohrenkamera, Gehörgang reinfilmen
und dann einfach mal gucken, welcher Podcast passt da jetzt dazu. Genau, finde ich super. Das ist eine super Idee, so machen wir das. Ja, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Tinnitus, glaube ich. Neues Problem. Neues Problem, körperlicher Verfall setzt sich fort. Und ich dachte Tinnitus, ich kenne das von Joko, Joko hat Tinnitus gehabt oder hat er noch und er hat erzählt, das ging los in Phasen, wo er sehr viel Stress hatte. Und dann dachte ich mir, ach so, ich habe keinen Stress eigentlich. Fährt ein Auto, fährt ein lauten Auto vorbei. Auto hier durch die Wand. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich habe eigentlich kein so stressiges Leben. Und jetzt mal im Vergleich zu irgendwie einem Feuerwehrmann, der immer diese Stange hoch und runter rutschen muss. Oder Stefan Tietze, der irgendwie zu Hause sitzt und ständig Urlaub macht und da das einzige Problem ist, welche Farbe soll jetzt das T-Shirt haben, das ich heute anziehe. Das sieht nicht mein Leben aus. Und ganz verrückterweise, ich war wirklich sehr entspannt, ich lag auf einer Matratze, aber ohne Decke. Also es war keine Einschlaffsituation, sondern ich lag einfach auf der Matratze, wirklich so mit den Armen verschränkt, also wirklich wie so Entspannung. Hui, Decke. Ich lag auf der Decke. Und das sind, finde ich, entspannende Momente, wo du auf der Decke deines Betts liegst, so mit versträngten Armen, also wirklich fast so Stock-Foto-Image Entspannung und plötzlich Tinnitus. Und ich dachte mir, nee, mancher hast ja auch so einen hellen Ton, der dann gleich wieder weggeht. Und ich dachte mir, das muss sowas sein, weil ich habe gerade wirklich super entspannt. Ja, aber manchmal kommt es ja genau in solchen Momenten. Also ich kenne das Kopfschmerzen an Sonntagen. Auch ein guter Titel leider, verdammt. Leider auch ein guter Titel. The Queen of the Grace their Headaches at Sunday. Ja, könnte der Untertitel sein. The Queen of Grace, Kopfschmerzen am Sonntag. Auch Englisch und Deutsch gemischt. Das passt für dich eigentlich. Mir gefällt auch auf Englisch das Grace und Grace. Also Grace. Grace. Auch The Queen of Grace. Gefällt mir alles gut. Okay. Genau, aber an dem einzigen Tag in der Woche, wo ich eigentlich nicht gearbeitet habe, hatte ich Kopfschmerzen. Okay. Okay. Das war eine Zeit, da habe ich sehr viel gemacht. Da war Uni parallel zu Neo Magazine, erste Staffeln. Ah, okay, das war ganz lang her. Nee, nee, ganz lang her. Als du dir noch deine Lorbeeren verdienen musstest, auf denen du dich heute ausrustest. Auf denen ich mich seit Jahren, die ist inzwischen zu Nesseln geworden, in denen ich jetzt hocke. Aber da habe ich sehr viel gearbeitet, sehr viel gemacht, kaum Privatleben. Und das war eine Zeit, da habe ich immer Sonntagskopfschmerzen gehabt. Also genau an diesen Situationen, wo man sich mal auf die Bette gelegt. Weil dein Körper dann gesagt hat, hier fehlt was, ich bin so viel Stress gewohnt, jetzt muss ich Stress machen. Ich glaube, es ist der einzige Moment, wo ihm auffällt, dass es ihm nicht gut geht, weil er muss sonst immer funktionieren und dann hast du ja irgendwie Adrenalin oder sowas oder so Momente, in denen du funktionieren musst. Kennst du ja auch Bühnenadrenalin, dann geht es so, er hat dann mega funktioniert plötzlich und das Gehirn funktioniert schneller, aber sobald er die Bühne verlässt, bricht dann wieder die Krankheit über dich herein. Ja, das ist unser Leben. Als jemand, der hinter der Bühne immer zusammenbricht, was ich aus erster Hand erfahre. Wenn ihr genau guckt, und Stefan geht von der Bühne, man kann teilweise noch zwischen den Spalt im Vorhang noch sehen, wie er zusammenbricht. Wie er schon wieder am Boden liegt, wie eingeschlafen ist. Wie er schon in die nächsten Nesseln sich reinlegt und einfach da drin liegen bleibt.
Geht's unten in den Nesseln?
Das ist für mich auch ein Problem, weil Stefan muss nach einem Auftritt erstmal zwei Stunden schlafen.
Und ich weiss oft nicht, soll ich schon gehen, soll ich ihn liebkosen im weitesten Sinne, soll ich ihm eine Decke überlegen?
Ich habe dir schon mal gesagt, ich fände es zumindest schön, wenn er in der Nachricht liegt.
Weil wenn wir zusammen einen Auftritt hatten und ich schlafe ein und ich wache auf und du bist nicht mehr da, immer unschönes Gefühl. Ja, ja. Wenn du aber dann zumindest eine Nachricht hinterlässt, es war schön mit dir, hier ist meine Telefonnummer, wir sehen uns bis bald. Hey, du hast meine Telefonnummer, aber ich will die nochmal. Ich meine, aber so eine Nachricht wäre halt schöner. Okay. Okay, mehr Zettel, mehr Zettel, okay. Jetzt wo du dieses Schwarz trägst, not a fan. Ja, nee, ich seh's auch nicht. Schwarz weg, Weiss weg, all deine Farben. Du hast ja schon Schwarz und Weiss, ne? Aber kannst du jetzt zumindest mal mit diesem dämlichen Mythos aufräumen, Schwarz ist keine Farbe und so Nonsens. Oh, weiß ich nicht. Was man ständig hört, so was immer dieses Der Daumen ist kein Finger, Weiss ist keine Farbe und so ein nonnesen was man ständig hört so was immer dieses der daumen ist kein finger weiss ist keine farbe und ich denke mir doch ist es schon weil was soll das also natürlich ist eine farbe das sind diese pedanten die dann immer sich an solchen sachen aufhängen wo jedes gespräch immer wie kriege ich dieses gespräch jetzt dazu zu schwarz oder weiss zu kommen, damit ich sagen kann, dass weiss keine Farbe ist. Ich habe mir jetzt, ich habe mir ein neues Auto gekauft, ein Audi A8 in weisser Farbe. Weiss keine Farbe! Was soll er heißen? Der Auto hat mich gefragt, soll es rot, grün oder weiss sein? Ich habe gesagt, weiss. Also warum? Das stimmt, ne? Das ist so ein Nonsens einfach. Die Bankt bei Auto, jeder weiß beim Autokauf steht dann da, du musst eine Farbe auswählen, du kannst Weiss anklicken. Ja natürlich, vor allem, also wenn du schon dieser Nervpedant bist, dann liefer doch bitte eine Alternative. Was ist denn Weiss sonst? Also alles ist irgendwas, nichts ist nichts, alles ist in irgendeiner Kategorie drin. Und wenn du sagst, boah, fuck, ich hab echt Probleme mit meinem Finger, ich hab mir einen Daumen gebrochen. Daumen sind keine Finger. Ja, was denn dann? Ein Daumen, ein Zwergplanet. Direkt ummacht. Ja, das ist das Problem. Was denn dann? Was ist Pluto denn dann? Ja, genau. Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Wenn Erdbeeren ein Nuss ist und Erdnüsse eine Frucht sind, dann haben wir vielleicht als Menschheit einen Fehler gemacht. Richtig. Dann sind wir vielleicht falsch abgebogen. Wenn Pluto kein Planet ist und die Sonne kein Planet, wenn Sterne keine Planeten sind und die Erde kein Stein ist, wenn die Menschen aus Wasser bestehen und die Gurke auch, wenn Weiss keine Farbe ist und der Applativ kein Fall, dann können wir jetzt Feierabend machen. Immer Feierabend. Erst wenn Weiss eine Farbe ist und Erdbeer eine Frucht und der Daumen einen Finger, dann kann die Menschheit wirklich anfangen, los zu blühen. Wir alle drehen durch gerade ein bisschen, die ganze Welt dreht durch, Despoten, überall, Despoten.
Du kommst aber, ich stand im Stau, ich stand im Stau vor mir, ganz Kölner Innenstadt, vorher Despoten.
Ich denk mir, sag mal Leute, geht's noch? Warum hat niemand die Demokratie verteidigt?
Jetzt haben wir hier überall Despoten, an jeder Ecke Despoten bei Starbucks, ich warte mir die Beine in den Kopf.
Deswegen war das ja damals mit dem Anschlag beim Köln-Marathon.
So, ich will...
Äh.
Timing. Stefan, Timing.
So. Vielen Dank für die Folge,
ich glaube, es ist ein gutes Timing. Danke für die Folge,
vielen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart, herzlich willkommen,
wir kamen jetzt leider nicht zu euren Fragen,
aber das machen wir dann nächste Woche. Bis dahin, haut rein!
Wir reichen wieder nach, macht's gut, macht's gut! Tschüss, wir heben ab!